สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 201
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 5
เดือนอะไรคะ
สิงหาคม
มีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
อีคอส
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลาบ่ายโมง
บ่ายโมงกี่นาที
28 นาทีค่ะ
ยังไม่กินครูฟ้าก็ต้องหิว
มากแล้วจะโอเคไหม
ไม่
โอเคเอาต้องกินค่ะกินอะไรคะกูก็มีนมอยู่
นะคะ
ผู้หญิงตกใจมากเลยนะคะตอนแรกที่ครูฟ้า
หยิบมาแล้วผู้หญิงเห็นแค่ขวดข้างบนผู้
หญิงคิดว่ามันเป็นยาสระผม
หรืออะไรสักอย่างที่แบบว่าเป็นน้ำยาทำ
ความสะอาดห้องน้ำอ๋อนมเพราะมีนมอยู่
ผู้หญิงรู้ได้ยังไงคะ
ใช่เพราะว่าครูฟ้าต้องโอเคนะวันนี้เนี่ย
ครูหญิงจะมีเกมมาให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดนะคะ
ครูฟ้าต้องคิดว่าต้องใช้ IQ ใช้สมองมี
สมองข้างในครูฟ้าต้องคิดแต่ว่าไม่ใช่คิด
แบบเป็นตัวเลขแบบหนึ่งบวกหนึ่งเท่ากับ
เท่าไรหรือว่าครูหญิงมีคำถาม
ประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยมีกี่จังหวัดไม่ใช่คำถามไม่ต้อง
คิดแบบอะไรๆไม่ใช่แต่เป็นการคิดอีกอย่าง
หนึ่งใช่ว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ดูมีรูปนะผู้หญิงก็จะมีรูป
จะมีรูปที่ 1
มีรูปนะคะในรูปเนี่ยก็จะมีกรอบสี่กรอบใช่
ไหมก็จะมีเรื่องราวเนี่ยรูปที่ 1 รูปที่ 2
รูปที่ 3 แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่าแล้วรูป
ที่ 4 เนี่ยมันจะเกิดอะไรมันจะมีเหตุ
การณ์อะไรเกิดขึ้นนักเรียนอาจจะฟังครูฟ้า
อาจจะฟังแล้วแบบอะไรอ่ะไม่เข้าใจใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงมีรูปมีตัวอย่างไม่ต้องเป็นตัว
อย่างนี้เป็นข้อแรกเลยนะคะเห็นไหมในรูป
นี้เนี่ยจะมีกรอบสี่เหลี่ยมอยู่กรอบที่
เดิมกรอบที่ 2 กรอบที่ 3
กล่องที่ 3 มองไม่ค่อยเห็นเนาะกรอบที่ 4
ใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ในกรอบที่ 4 เนี่ยไม่มีอะไรเลยมันว่าง
เปล่ากรอบที่ 4 นี่แหละค่ะครูฟ้าต้องเป็น
คนคิดว่า
มันจะเกิดเหตุการณ์อะไรต่อไปมันเป็น
การ์ตูน
สมัยมันเป็นการ์ตูนอ่า
กรอบที่ 1 เนี่ยมีอะไรคะครูฟ้ากรอบ
ดูหน้าเนี่ย
ยังไงคะหน้าของปลา
หน้าเบื่อๆ
ว่ายน้ำทุกวัน
ใช่แบบว่า
อันนี้อะไรคะ
หน้าของปลาเหรอ
เหมือนมันเบื่อใช่ไหมคะทุกวันมันก็ว่าย
น้ำ
ตื่นนอนเอ๊ะปลานอนไหมตื่นนอนมาก็ว่าให้
น้ำนอนอยู่ก็ว่ายน้ำอยู่เออมันก็เบื่อใช่
ไหมคะเอ้าแล้วในรูปที่ 2 เนี่ยหน้าของปลา
เนี่ยเปลี่ยนไปไหมคะครูฟ้า
หน้าของปลาเนี่ยนะคะ
เปลี่ยนค่ะ
ไม่เบื่อแล้วหรอเพราะว่าในรูปที่ 1 เนี่ย
หน้าแบบ
เบื่อมาก
ไม่เบื่อแล้วค่ะ
ปลาเหมือน
เห็น
อะไร
แล้วปลาทำหน้าอะไรคะเนี่ย
ปลาทำหน้าช็อคเซอร์ไพรส์
ตกใจ
อะไร
อะไรแล้วรูปที่ 3 ก็บอกเราใช่ไหมคะว่า
บาร์เนี่ย
เห็นอะไรคะที่ทำให้ปลาเนี่ยแบบตกใจ
หีบ
เป็นหีบที่วางอยู่ที่พื้นใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าต้องเป็นคนคิดว่าในรูปที่ 4 มัน
เกิดอะไรขึ้นปลาเนี่ยเห็นหีบแล้วปลาจะทำ
อะไรครูฟ้าต้องเป็นคนวาดครูฟ้าอยากว่า
เล็กๆในนี้หรือว่าอยากวาดใหญ่ๆคะใหญ่ๆ
แล้วกัน
ปลาเกิดอะไรขึ้น
ใช่ปลาเนี่ยว่ายน้ำมาแล้วก็มาเจอกับหีบ
แต่ว่ามันล็อคอยู่นะใช่ไหมหีบเนี่ยมัน
ล็อคอยู่เห็นไหมมันล็อคอยู่
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าในรูปต่อไปปลาจะทำอะไรไหม
หรือว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
อันนี้เป็นหีบใช่ไหมคะที่ปลาเนี่ยเจอ
ปลามันใหญ่มากนะคะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
เพราะว่าตายยังไงนะ
ยังไงก็ได้นักเรียนก็เล่นได้นะนักเรียนก็
ระหว่างดูระหว่างที่เสร็จแล้วนักเรียนก็
คิดว่าถ้าเป็นนักเรียนนักเรียนอยากจะวาด
อะไรในกรอบที่ 4 อันนี้ปลาของครูฟ้าทำไม
มันไม่ตกใจแล้วคุณดูเหนื่อยเหมือนเดิม
[เพลง]
มันต้องมากกว่านี้นะคะ
อ๋อมันต้องตาโตมากกว่าใช่ไหมคะ
นี่คือปลาเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ก็ต้องดู
นักเรียนอาจจะติดเองนักเรียนอาจจะแบบว่า
ไม่ได้ฟัง
ไม่ได้ฟังแล้วแดดจะดูแล้วก็คิดด้วยว่า
ครูฟ้าวาดอะไรพวกครูหญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือน
กันนะคะก็ดูแล้วก็คิดคล้ายๆกับครูคล้ายๆ
กับนักเรียนว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยว่าไอ้หีบเนี่ย
นะคะ
รูปที่สีหีบเนี่ยมันเปิดใช่ไหมเปิดแต่ผู้
หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่าเรื่องราวมันคือ
อะไร
ลาตัวนี้รู้สึกอะไร
ให้ครูฟ้าเล่าแล้วกันว่าครูฟ้าวาดอะไรคะ
ว่าเปิดออกมาแล้วข้างในเนี่ยมีปลาอีก 1
ตัว
หรือเปล่าใช่ไหมถูกต้องนะคะ
ซึ่ง
อันนี้เป็นปลาอะไรคะนักเรียนรู้ไหม
อยู่ออสเตรเลียก็เลยเห็นทุกอย่างเป็นปลา
ฉลามหรอคะ
ที่รัก
ใช่แล้วล่ะ
ฉลาม
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนอันนี้คือปลาฉลาม
คือปลาตัวที่ 1 ที่ว่ายน้ำมาแล้วก็เจอหีบ
พอเจอหีบปุ๊บก็เปิดหีบนั้นข้างในมีปลา
ฉลามอยู่ข้างในมีปลาฉลามแล้วปลาตัวนี้รู้
สึกอะไรคะหน้าแบบนี้เนี่ยที่กูฝากว่าอ่ะ
รู้สึก
กลัว
ผู้หญิงคิดเองดูหน้าแบบนี้แบบดีใจจน
ร้องไห้เจอคุณแม่อะไรแบบนี้อ๋อเจอปลาฉลาม
ก็กลัว
กลัวใช่ไหมคะกับรูปแรก
ได้ไหม
ได้ค่ะก็เปิดออกมาเราก็เจอปลาฉลามอยู่
ข้างในปลาตัวนี้ก็กลัวอันนี้คือรูปที่ 4
ของครูฟ้าใช่ไหมผู้หญิงวาดรูปที่ 5 ได้
ค่ะถ้าเป็นรูปที่ 5 ต่อไปก็คือฉลามก็
กินปลาตัวนี้ The  End จบ
จบแบบสไตล์ครูฟ้าจริงๆนะคะ
โอเคต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
อันนี้ปลาอีกแล้วนะคะคุณหญิงชอบปลาหรือ
เปล่าแต่อันนี้เนี่ยคือปลาปักเป้าปลาที่
นักเรียนเห็นเป็นวงกลมเนี่ยนะคะเวลาที่
เราไปโดนมันใช่ไหมมันก็จะแบบตอนแรกเนี่ย
ตอนแรกมันก็เป็นปลาธรรมดาแบบนี้ไหม
พอ
เราโดนปุ๊บมันก็จะแบบพองตัวมันจะพองตัว
แล้วก็เป็นวงกลมนะคะปลาปักเป้า
น่าจะว่ายน้ำอยู่เหมือนกันรูปที่ 2 เนี่ย
มันก็พองใหญ่ขึ้นรูปที่ 3 ใหญ่ขึ้นแล้วก็
รูปที่ 4 เนี่ยมันมีเสียง
ป๊อปของไทยมันก็น่าจะเป็นเสียง
ขอบคุณค่ะเสียงเหมือนมันแปลกอ่ะเหมือน
อะไรที่มันเป็นวงกลมค่ะแล้วมันโดนเจาะมัน
ก็แบบ
มันกลมแล้วมันใหญ่ขึ้นมันใหญ่ขึ้นมันใหญ่
ขึ้นแล้วมันก็เลยแตกใช่ไหมดังปั้งก็ได้
ค่ะแล้วรูปต่อไปให้ครูฟ้าวาดว่า
เหตุการณ์ต่อไปมันคืออะไรมันจะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นให้กูฟ้าววาด
ตาปักเป้าเนี่ยมันพองตัว
พองตัวพองตัวพองตัวใหญ่ขึ้นแล้วก็แตก
อะไรอันนี้ก็แล้วแต่ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าต้องคิด
อยากให้เป็นอะไรก็ได้นะคะอันนี้ไม่มีไม่
มีถูกไม่มีผิดใช่ไหมถูกผิดเนี่ย
ไม่มี
ครูฟ้าอยากให้เรื่องมันเป็นยังไงก็ได้
การ์ตูน
ผู้ชายหรือเปล่าหรือว่าผู้หญิงหรือว่า
เป็นคนว่าผู้หญิงเห็นครูฟ้าวาดหน้าแล้วก็
มีคิ้วมีตา
เหมือนเป็นคน
อ้อเป็นเห็นผมยาวๆน่าจะเป็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงรู้แล้ว
ผู้หญิงเดาถูก
แต่ไม่พูดดีกว่า
เพราะนักเรียนก็เดาถูกนะ
คะ
นางเงือกน้อย
มีเอวหน่อย
นางเงือกน้อยว่ายน้ำทุกวันออกกำลังกายนะ
คะ
ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะวาดเป็นผู้
ชายหรอแฟนของครูฟ้า
ซุปเปอร์สตาร์นักร้องเกาหลี
สะบัดครีบมากนะคะ
แตกออกมาเป็นลูกครึ่งปลาเหรอคะครึ่งคน
ครึ่งปลา aly  Mermaid นางเงือกใช่ไหม
เงือกนะ
เห็นด้วยกับครูฟ้าไหม
มี
ก็ได้เนาะเวลามันแตกออกมาข้างในมันเป็น
อะไรก็ได้ไง
อ๋อแต่ของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
มันแตก
แล้วก็ออกมามีนางเงือกสมัยนางเงือกน้อย
เนี่ยออกมา
ใช่แล้วเป็นลูก
[เพลง]
เป็นนางเงือกน้อยที่เป็นลูกครึ่งคนลูก
ครึ่งนึงเป็นคนครึ่งนึงเป็นปลาปักเป้า
เหรอคะ
มันจะมีอันนี้ด้วยใช่ไหมมีหนามมีหนามมี
หนามมีหนามมีหนามแหลมๆอ่ะ
นางมันแตกออกมาเป็นนางเงือกจะมีหนามแหลมๆ
ด้วยไหม
นางเงือกก็มีหนาม
แล้วถ้าเราไปโดนไปโดนหางไปโดนตัวนางเงือก
จะพองตัวไหม
ว่านักเรียนคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าไหมก็ comment
บอกได้นะถ้าคิดไม่เหมือนนะคะ
อีก 1 อันคิดว่าได้อีก 1 อันนะคะ
แอร์สกายไม่ให้เอเรียลนะคะ
ไม่ใช่แอเรียล
ก็คือกูฟ้านั่นเอง
อ่ะสกายไม่ใช่ The  Sky นะคะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
เหมือนกัน
อันที่แล้วเป็นปลาใช่มั้ยรูปนี้เนี่ยเป็น
ไข่นะคะไข่อะไรก็ไม่รู้แต่เป็นไข่ 1 ฟอง
รูปที่ 2 เนี่ยมันก็เริ่มมีรอยร้าวมัน
เริ่มแตกใช่ไหมคะรูปที่ 3 เนี่ยมันก็
เริ่มแตกมากขึ้นจนรูปที่ 4 เนี่ยมันก็แตก
แต่ยังไงอ่ะ
เสียงเป็นยังไงคะครูฟ้า
แล้วแตกออกมาเป็นอะไรอันนี้เป็นนางเงือก
น้อยไม่ได้นะคะมันเป็นไข่นะไม่ใช่ปลา
ให้ครูฟ้าวาด
แตกออกมาเป็นอะไร
หรือว่า
มันต้องแตกออกมาเป็นอะไรล่ะเนาะ
[เพลง]
หรือว่าแตกออกมาแล้วมีเรื่องราวอะไรก็ได้
หรือว่าไม่แตกก็ได้
ก็แล้วแต่จะวาดให้เป็นการ์ตูนอะไรก็ได้
นักเรียนคิดว่า
นักเรียนคิดว่ามันจะเกิดอะไรต่อไปถ้า
เรียนคิดว่าครูฟ้ากำลังวาดอะไรอยู่ใช่ไหม
ที่มันเป็นเส้นๆผู้หญิงคิดว่าเป็นงูเหรอ
คะ
อนาคอนด้า
หรือเปล่า
แต่ว่านี่เห็นเป็นฟันนะ
ตรงนี้อ่ะตรงนี้ก็คือฟันใช่ไหมมีฟันมีตา
แล้วหน้าก็ดูยาวๆแบบนี้ไม่น่าจะใช่หน้าคน
ตอนนี้เป็นจมูกใช่ไหมคะ
ไดโนเสาร์
อุ๊ยผู้หญิงรู้ได้ยังไงคะ
เดาเอาไงก็ดูจากครูฟ้าว่าดูจากหน้าดูจาก
ปากดูจากไข่ไดโนเสาร์
แล้วเราจะอยู่ยังไง
เพราะว่าขาอะไรนะอันนี้เป็นขาใช่ไหมขา
หน้าสั้นๆน่ะเป็นทีเร็กซ์ด้วยนะ
ไม่ใช่เป็นไดโนเสาร์ที่ใจดี
นักเรียนบอกว่าอันอื่นไม่รู้อะไรแต่ว่า
หน้าแล้วก็ขาโอเคดูแล้วเข้าใจว่าเป็น
ไดโนเสาร์
มีไข่นักเรียนบอกว่านักเรียนดูรูปที่ 1
โอเคนะเพราะรูปที่ 2 ปลาเนี่ยแตกออกมา
แล้วก็เป็น
นางเงือกน้อยใช่ไหมคะเพราะรูปที่ 3 เนี่ย
ไข่ไข่มันกำลังแตกออกมาแล้วก็เป็น
ไดโนเสาร์นักเรียนคิดว่าอ๋อครูฟ้าชอบดู
หนังดู The  Little  Mermaid ดู Jurassic
Park  Jurassic  World
ครูฟ้าน่าจะชอบดูหนัง
ตาเมื่อกี้นี้โอเคแล้วล่ะค่ะครูฟ้า
อัน
นี้ดูเหมือนจระเข้มากกว่าไดโนเสาร์
แล้วเราก็ต้องมาวิ่งหนีไดโนเสาร์กันเหรอ
คะครูฟ้า
กันไงเพราะว่าชีวิต
กินคนนะคะเห็นครูหญิงเห็นครูฟ้าเนี่ยจับ
แล้วก็กินนะคะ
โอเคค่ะนักเรียนคิดนักเรียนไม่ต้องตอบนะ
คะว่านักเรียนจะวาดอะไรเป็นรูปต่อไปนัก
เรียนอาจจะดูเสร็จแล้วถ้านักเรียนอยาก
comment คุยกันก็คือนักเรียนคิดยังไงกับ
ที่ครูฟ้าว่าเห็นด้วยกับครูฟ้าไว้ว่าอ๋อ
ไข่ Off มาเป็นไดโนเสาร์นะคะก็ comment
คุยกันได้เนาะส่วนวีดีโอนี้นะคะครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ